hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that happened a few days ago
on 26th of January in the seventh round
of the Bulgarian Championship it's a
game between International master nurul
salimova and the Fiji Master laches are
yordanov and the reason why I was
suggested and it was suggested on
Twitter by an account that follows
women's games when women do really well
in chess for example in a single game or
in a tournament and here salimova did
incredibly well in the Bulgarian
Championship
um and uh that that's why it was uh it
was requested I will put a link to this
account in the description below if you
guys want to follow it if you're
interested in more more news from uh
from women's chess in particular and she
finished in second place there were
seven Grand Masters playing the
Bulgarian championship and she finished
ahead of six of them so second place she
only lost the the gentleman that won
first place he had a half a point more
than her I think had like six and a half
she had six uh but we're gonna discuss
the standings after we check out the
actual game because this is a quite an
attacking Masterpiece so let's dive
straight into it uh noodle with the
white pieces opens with Ponte E4 we have
Pawn to C5 uh larches are goes for the
Sicilian Defense Knight to F3 we have D6
sorry about that
uh and pawn to D4 striking in the center
as one always does see captures Knight
captures and now Knight to F6 with
Knight the C3 and A6 the neither of
Sicilian is on the board with Bishop to
G5 and now Knight B to D7 uh we have
Queen to E2 a bit of a uh funky funky
line but it it's nothing you know it has
been played before you just want to
Castle as quickly as possible so E6
Queen side castles and now Queen to C7
and now Ponte F4 striking um uh in in
the center and now of course the white
uh has to figure out how to go about
this position and black will do the
usual stuff like Bishop D7 uh you're
gonna play some like B5 you're gonna
maybe try and Advance the pawn to B4 uh
it will either be uh castles of opposite
sides or black will keep the king in the
center of the board and uh will try to
attack white on the queen side and here
we have the immediate B5 and now white
has to decide uh salimova can choose
between something like a A3 which is the
standard reply to B5 you want to stop
that B4 push F5 is an idea in some
variations even E5 is an idea like a
straight out Pawn sacrifice in this one
obviously doesn't work but if you have a
similar position always uh keep in mind
that sometimes E5 is a possibility you
could also Play Bishop characters on on
F6 so many possibilities here she goes
for Pawn to F5 puts pressure on the D6
pawn and of course the black has to
react to this and black does so by
playing Pawn to B4 this is the best way
to react and it says that white should
have maybe played A3 but okay it's still
playable uh it's just gonna be a
complete mess on the board so F
characters on E6 B countries and C3 we
have e captress and D7 with check
uh Knight captures on D7 and now Queen
to C4 offering a queen trade uh C
captures on B2 with check King to B1 and
now uh usually in this position black
just traces uh the Queen's Queen
captures Bishop captures and then the
game continues with something like 95
you attack the bishop you attack you you
start developing uh and so on but here
uh Jordana wanted more and he played the
Knight to C5 so he keeps the Queens on
the board and now uh it's uh uh you know
gonna be a a much more uh exciting game
than it would be with the queens of the
board and there is a game where Bishop
the E2 was played but here she goes for
Ponte E5 and it is now as of move 15
that we have a completely new game and
now you already uh see some very very uh
crazy ideas that are possible here uh
black should play Rook the B8 but I'm
not gonna tell you why black should play
this uh in the game black played the D
captures on E5 he did not react maybe in
the in the best possible way to this
spawn push because now there is a very
clean way to take advantage of this I'm
sure you you see glimpses of what it
could be and maybe even the whole thing
but just in case feel free to pause the
video and try to find the absolute best
move for nurgul uh while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this wild
attacking idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Knight
to B5 that's how you do it and now the
problem is you can't just move the queen
if you move the queen somewhere weird
then Rook to d8 is Checkmate of course
you're not gonna allow that so the
Knight has to be captured a captures on
B5 and now not Queen characters with
Czech but rather Queen to D5 now the
threat is Queen captures an A8 but also
if you if you play something weird like
Rook the B8 now even though the queen is
guarding the d8 square you still have
this Checkmate you just trade queens and
then Rook capture 78 will be Checkmate
once again and the best way to play this
could be F6 but this just looks uh I
mean this just looks dead lost like
Bishop captures and B5 with check and
after King t7 you're gonna pick up the
rook and now black really doesn't have
any good options if you try to uh take
the bishop then Rook H to F1 and now
well if that black king can survive on
that ee7 square uh I mean then obviously
we we know nothing about Chess
so instead after Queen the D5 uh we have
Knight to D7 this way stopping uh Queen
38 and now just Queen captures an A8
grabbing that Rook we have Bishop to C5
now if black can Castle then black will
be perfectly fine even uh even better
the the white king will be the one in
trouble but of course nurgil does not
allow that she plays a rook captures on
D7 the absolute best way to keep the
king in the center of the board uh you
can't capture the bishop spin you can't
capture with the queen if Queen captures
then you just play Bishop captures on B5
this is Unstoppable Queen has to capture
and then just a queen characters and C8
will be Checkmate so instead after Rook
captures and D7 you can't play this you
can't play this you have to play this
King captures on D7 but now Bishop
captures and V5 check look at this King
the E6 and now Bishop the C4 with check
and you can't go back if you go King D6
then Queen to D5 is Checkmate if you go
up the board King to D 7 not much better
Queen to A4 with check and look at this
the Queen Bishop combo it's um there are
no moves here if you block with the
queen just Bishop B5 it's uh Unstoppable
so after Bishop to C4 check King the F5
the black king has to merely continue uh
on his uh Journey uh we have pawned the
H4 just defending the bishop now
preparing to to bring the the black king
even closer so King to G6 Now Pawn to G4
and The Rook to f8 you don't really gain
anything by H6 because Bishop to D3 will
take away this diagonal from the black
king uh so here uh latches are tries
rooked f8 he's ready to meet Bishop to
F3 Bishop to D3 with F5 but it is uh
insufficient Bishop to D3 check we have
Ponta F5 not g captures an F5 with check
and now uh there are a couple of moves
you could play a king to F7 will run
into a very quick Checkmate after Queen
to D5 uh but you could consider Bishop
captures on F5 it's possible as the rook
and f8 is defended by the bishop and C5
the problem is after Queen to G2 again
not not much to be done here now you're
just threatening for example to win the
not that but to win the black queen and
let's say King to F7 now you go back
Queen D5 track and after Bishop E6 Rook
to F1 check and that's it there's no way
to a Defenders the bishop will fall
whatever you play uh like Queen captures
King h8 Rook captures Bishop captures
and uh you're up a full piece and a very
quickly black will get checkmated so
instead after G captures an F5 Rook
captures on F5 it's not much but it kind
of prolongs the game a little bit longer
uh Bishop captures with Chuck King
captures and now Rook to F1 with check
King back to E6 and now Queen to E4 uh
so what can what can the black queen do
a king do uh White is even up material
so this is unplayable completely but
okay Bishop to D4 it's possible that you
still make something out of it Queen
captures on H7 we have kinked the D5
Queen back to D3 with Bishop to E6 and
now Bishop to E3 uh sorry Bishop D3
offering a trade of Bishops uh so Queen
to A7 hoping that maybe this diagonal
opens up once the black king moves maybe
you can Checkmate the white king but not
really just Bishop captures e captures
and now Rook to E1 uh and even if you
try something like let's say King D6 you
put pressure on the A2 Pawn just A3 this
is uh
uh this is nothing blackhead black has
absolutely no moves here so after rookie
one Bishop to F7 was played with Queen
to B5 check now completely locking out
the the black king king to D6 with Ponte
A4 and now Bishop to D5 Queen to B4 with
tracking to C6 and now Rook to E7 and he
was in this position unmove 37 that
latches that rodanov resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
now you I remove the the black queen and
you get checkmated or you try to trade
Queens but this also doesn't work you
just pick up the pawn now a very simple
end game Rook against Bishop Europa Pawn
this is winning however you want to play
it like just push the H Pawn and you win
uh so yeah after Rook D7 uh very nicely
done by uh by uh salimova a brilliant
victory in round seven and yeah I mean
the game just exploded out of nowhere
after this King to B1 move uh usually
players trade Queens uh but he wanted to
keep the Queens on the board uh Knight
to C5 and then after E5 uh the position
uh absolutely collapsed so like I said
you you can play Rook the B8 here and
the game continues but if you don't know
this if you try to try to play the
position like not knowing uh not knowing
it by heart uh you will just uh collapse
like it happened in this game uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
these are the final standings after nine
rounds of the Bulgarian Championship you
can see that uh the tournament was born
uh won by kiril georgiev uh who defeated
salimova uh and uh he finishes the
tournament with six and a half points
but then you have in second place with
six points uh salimova uh so really
really incredible in there you can see
Grandma
nicolov so a lot of Grandmasters behind
her like I counted six as there were
seven of them in total so yeah
absolutely a spectacular achievement uh
I didn't find how much rating she won in
the tournament uh as uh you know yeah
it's it's uh it's harder than you might
imagine but yeah if any of you can find
this information do share and I will pin
your comments so everyone else can see
in the comments because I imagine it's
uh it's quite a lot uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it once
again thank you for suggesting it and if
you want to follow the uh the accounts
that suggested this game to me that
follows uh uh women's games and when
women do well uh we'll put a link to it
in the description below uh so you you
can follow it on Twitter uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
I would like to thank virtual reality
piano YouTube Tara Scorpio Sasha video
and Paul uh hinamund for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on you
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day